- One, two, go, they have
asked you to leave three times.
Three times they have
asked you to leave.
- Ok, but I have to
tell you something.
- Three times.
- I'm sorry, jail time.
- Here we go.
- [Male Officer] Go to jail.
No, no, no. We're going to jail.
- I just have to
do something, ok?
- [Male Officer]
What are you doing?
What do you have to do?
- I have to change my boots.
- Don't change
- I have to take off my shoes.
- Ok, they're dangerous,
they are dangerous
they're dangerous,
they're very sharp.
- These shoes are real pretty.
- Ok, I'm putting these in here.
- Wait, hold on,
I just wanna put
- Come on, come on,
come on, come on
- Get up! Missy. Missy.
- What?
- You are not wearing any pants.
Now you cover yourself.
- I gotta can I put my pants on?
- Yes, yes, you
can put pants on.
- But I wanna pick
out which ones.
- How 'bout this?
- I don't wanna wear those.
- All right, which
ones do you want?
- I wanna wear the
ones, the ones there.
- How 'bout these?
- These are good,
these are just fine.
- No! (bleep)
- Hey, hey, hey, hey.
- These.
- I don't wanna wear those.
(bleep)
- That's real pretty.
- No, no, it's beautiful.
- I don't think this is mine.
- This is (bleep) Charity's,
I don't wanna wear
her stupid skirt.
- Panties, wait a second.
- This is on backwards.
- Oh no.
- There you go.
(screams)
Now come on.
- Wait, wait, wait,
I forgot something.
- What, what did you forget?
- I forgot something.
- What did you forget?
- My cell phone.
- Where is it?
- It's in the bar.
- [Male Officer] In the bar?
- Mmm-hmm.
- Are you lying to me?
- [Female Officer] Noo!
- [Male Officer] Son of a bitch!
Son of a bitch!
- [Female Officer]
No you did not!
You come back here!
- I smoke a cigarette?
- In the car you can.
- Well can I smoke one first,
'cause I just have to wait
I'm waiting for a
phone call inside.
Do you have a light?
- Yes, of course I do.
Now we're going to be good,
and we're gonna be friends,
and we're not gonna run, and
we're not gonna puke, right?
- No, no I No!
Son of a bitch, she tricked me!
It was a trick!
She's a little (bleep) genius.